il y à 70 ans david ben gourion
proclamer la création de l'état d'israël
pour celles et ceux qui avaient entendu
théodore hertzl théorisé l'état des
juifs 50 ans auparavant pour ceux peu
nombreux qu'ils avaient échappé à la
shoah il y avait ce jour là un immense
espoir une délivrance est un
accomplissement
nous aurions aimé retrouver cette
atmosphère au lieu de cela depuis hier
nous avons en mémoire des images
difficiles de morts par dizaines et deux
blessés par milliers au moment même où
était inaugurée à jérusalem
l'ambassade des états unis monsieur le
premier ministre
quelles initiatives la france peut-elle
encore engagées pour retrouver dans
cette région tourmentée qui peut
s'embraser à tout moment le chemin de la
paix je vous remercie
la journée d'hier à gaza a été la plus
meurtrière depuis 2014 avec près de 60
morts
démineurs et près de 2700 blessés dont
beaucoup par balles la france condamne
évidemment est sans aucune ambiguïté ces
violences
car si nous sommes sans aucune ambiguïté
attachés à la sécurité d'israël
nous ne pouvons pas accepter un tel
niveau de violence face au droit
fondamental des palestiniens à
manifester pacifiquement le politique de
la france elle est connue elle est
ancienne elle a pour objectif deux états
israël et la palestine vivant dans la
paix la sécurité au sein de frontières
reconnues avec jérusalem pour capitale
des deux états c'est ce que dit le droit
c'est la ligne défendue par la france
dimanche la barbarie islamiste a volé la
vie d'un jeune homme de 29 ans l'horreur
se répète
anne attentats de plus qui a donné lieu
à de grandes et belles phrases un
philosophe a parlé de sidération rituel
la consternation les indignation
légitime ne sont plus suffisantes
on a le sentiment que l'accoutumance au
terrorisme islamiste nous guette
or il ya pire que l'horreur
il y à l'accoutumance à l'horreur les
réponses au terrorisme ne sont bien sûr
technique la qualité du travail des
forces de l'ordre et du renseignement
mérite d'être salué mais une vraie
réponse passe aussi et surtout si l'on
veut agir à long terme par un réarmement
moral et culturel de notre pays nous ne
réglerons pas la question des attentats
si nous laissons des quartiers entiers
de notre territoire réchappe échapper
aux lois de la république
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le premier
ministre il est temps pour la france de
déclarer l'état d'urgence culturelle et
morale
oui il faut combattre idéologiquement ce
terrorisme cet islamisme radical qui
amène à tuer dans nos quartiers il faut
peut-être faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait
pas dans nos grandes villes à la fois
des endroits prospère et puis des
quartiers qui se paupérise qui se
ghettoïse parce que à force de vivre
côte à côte en finit un jour par vivre
face à face alors oui la lutte doit être
menée sur tous les plans à la fois par
l'action policière et en même temps par
l'action culturelle par la bataille
intellectuelle et c'est tous ensemble
que nous devons la gagner
[Musique]